interesting fact that most people don't
know is that in order for a man to be
aroused
in order for a man to get an erection he
has to be in a parasympathetic dominant
state within his nervous system
so he actually has to be in a more
restful more calm digestive state in
order to get aroused so a lot of the
non-medical erectile dysfunction
problems that happen a lot of the
non-medical premature ejaculation
challenges that men face is not because
there's something physically going wrong
besides the fact that they can't get out
of that stress State they literally
cannot move their body out of this place
of the breath is going really fast their
heart rate is elevated their body's
releasing cortisol stress hormones
adrenaline Etc